Alr
hello hello guys. Donc aujourd'hui vidéo
sur les 11 niveau d'utilisation de Lia.
Donc euh souvent on parle de di mais euh
sans la sans quantifier son niveau euh
de son utilisation de l'IA euh ben on
peut vite plafonner si on n'écoute pas
euh des vidéos, si on s'éduque pas, si
on se garde pas à jour, euh on peut
rapidement plafonner puis penser qu'on
est rendu au niveau le plus supérieur
puis euh peut-être le seul qui est
atteignable pour nous. Peut-être que les
autres, on sait pas exactement c'est
quoi, on comprend pas. fait qu'on se dit
qu' sont inatteignables.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on va
euh les décortiquer. On va voir qu'au
final euh c'est potentiellement plus
accessible
que euh on le croit. Donc euh let's go.
Donc
la réalité du marché en 2026, c'est que
la majorité des gens utilisent l' comme
un Google qui est juste plus rapide.
Donc qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là ?
c'est que les gens vont juste poser des
questions, ils vont l'utiliser comme une
sorte de de guide un peu une sorte de
c'est ça un Google que le monde va poser
des questions.
Euh puis la statistique c'est que 87 %
des utilisateurs s'arrêtent avant le
niveau 6. Donc là, on va voir qu'il y a
plusieurs niveaux euh
puis la majorité arrive au niveau 6,
mais il y en reste après ça. La vraie
ligne de démarcation est presque
invisible jusqu'à ce qu'on la nomme.
Donc c'est ça, si on nomme pas justement
les différents niveaux de Lia, ben on
pense peut-être qu'on est rendu au
maximum de du potentiel. Peut-être qu'on
pense que euh Lia finalement, c'est pas
aussi hute qu'on pensait. Donc euh c'est
ce qu'on va voir juste ici. Donc euh
directement, on va commencer. Donc
niveau 1 2, on pour dire c'est la zone
de confort. Donc euh c'est ça que la
grande majorité des gens utilisent euh
des utilisateurs IO, ilutilise
aujourd'hui. Donc niveau 1, c'est tout
simplement un moteur de recherche euh
amélioré. Donc pos des questions, des
résumés, réformulations. Donc au final,
c'est juste que Lia va remplacer Google.
Donc euh super simple mais beaucoup de
gens ça va être comme ça. Niveau 2,
c'est partenaire de réflexion donc ils
vont plus brainstorm avec euh validation
d'idées euh plan de projet ça plus comme
un collègue un peu. Même il y en a qui
vont euh le prendre un peu comme un
psychologue. Il y en a qui vont
justement vraiment il ont des problèmes
à job vont juste brainstorm avec ou
problème dans leur couple vont
brainstorm avec puis il y en a qui
justement c'est là que les histoires de
comme des gens qui tombent en amour avec
l' ça va arriver quand qu'ils sont
justement en partenariat de réflexion
ils se sentent compris tu sais enfin une
fois il encore enfin ils se sentent
compris tu sais
donc par la suite niveau 3 à 5 c'est là
que la plupart des des
power users se croit arriver. Il pense
avoir atteint ces numéros là fait qu'il
pensent qu'il ont comme atteint un gros
niveau, tu sais, en puis il pensent
qu'il ont comme quasiment le max, tu
sais. Puis euh
ceci dit, chaque personne à son niveau
potentiellement, il pense qu'il est
comme à son maximum qui peut atteindre.
Il pense qu'il peut pas, selon ses
compétences, il pense qu'il peut pas
aller plus loin. Après, ça c'est comme
trop complexe pour lui, tu sais. fait
chacun pense qu' comm une sorte de
plafond de vert aussi qui peut pas
atteindre plus de potentiel.
Niveau 3 vraiment un assistant personnel
donc là il va commencer à rédiger de
courriel des scripts. Donc va être comme
un employé invisible. Ils vont
l'utiliser comme une sorte d'employé.
Niveau 4 assistant connecté. Donc là on
va commencer plus à connecter la li à
tes données. Donc ton calendly, ton CRM,
tes fichiers euh probxte qui est réel tu
sais.
Donc potentiellement le monde ils vont
ils ont commencé à comme découvrir ça
avec Claude
Claude ben Claude et dans le fond que tu
pouvais directement pluguer tes
tes tes outils les tools euh même que
c'est rendu que chat GPT ils font Gemini
fait vraiment c'est rendu que ils
veulent rendre ça accessible au plus
grand nombre de personnes. Donc là, ils
vont mettre ça directement sur cloud
cloud
un niveau 5 spécialiste I donc plusieurs
modèles spécialisés donc un pour le
code, un pour la vente, un pour
l'analyse donc là il va commencer à
utiliser différents types fait que là il
va utiliser du CL code, il va utiliser
justement il va utiliser les différentes
forces des I pour s'aider du mieux
possible pour potentiellement peut-être
même maximiser optimiser son utilisation
de token.
Euh puis la plupart des gens se disent
"Je l'utilise bien, j'ai fait le tour
quand ils sont rendus à ce niveau là."
Quand ils sont rendus là, ils disent "E
j'ai plugué mes affaires entre eux, ça
fonctionne bien quand même mais il y a
encore du potentiel à aller chercher
l'optimisation à aller faire."
Donc c'est que la ligne de démarcation à
se fait. Donc là, tuas la zone de
salarié. Donc niveau 1 à 5, c'est tu es
un peu comme un salarié. Donc, tu vas
utiliser l'IA pour faire mieux ce que tu
faisais déjà. Chaque tâche encore
déclenché par un une un humain fait
c'est vraiment toi qui va tout le temps
actionner, qui copiercollé encore pour
travailler. Au final, tu vas être plus
rapide mais pas plus libre. tu vas faire
encore les tâches. Par la suite, ton
plafond reste fixé par ton nombre
d'heures. Donc encore une fois, tu vas
échanger des heures pour ton travail que
tu vas faire, mais il va être plus
rapide un peu. Puis les s'arrête quand
tu t'arrêtes. Puis la zone entrepreneur,
c'est les niveaux 6 à 11. Donc tu
délègues des fluxes entiers à des agents
autonomes. Les tâches les classes sans
toi, ton système travaille pendant que
tu dors. Le plafond égale la qualité de
ton architecture. Li continue même quand
tu es offline. Donc c'est ça qu'on va
voir de peut-être comment le faire euh
puis comment envisager justement cette
cette partie là de l'
donc tout d'abord le goulot
d'étranglement.
C'est pourquoi les niveaux 1 à 5 créent
un plafond ? Parce que même avec les
meilleurs outils, si c'est toujours toi
qui déclenche chaque action, tu scaleras
jamais. Tu sais fait que là on voit ici
que justement la tâche est déclenchée.
L'humain final, il est requis pour faire
cette tâche là, ben pour l'actionner. L
va exécuter, tu vas avoir un retour de
l'humain potentiellement ça va être bon,
mauvais à modifier puis tu vas devoir
reclencher ça, reenclencher ça. Puis tu
vas toujours devoir redonner le
contexte, tu vas toujours devoir donner
des feedback puis tu vas comme créer une
loop justement de c OK, c'était il m'a
donné de quoi pas pire. OK, bon on va
l'améliorer. OK, finalement il manque
encore telle à faire. En fait, là, tu
vas tout le temps avoir une loupe de
tout le temps devoir améliorer
continuellement puis redonner tes mêmes
feedback.
C'est là qu'on va voir comment améliorer
ça. Donc le niveau 6, c'est quand
travaille même quand tu dors. Donc à ce
niveau-là, euh l'agent autonome délégué
donc une séquence d'action qui se
déclenche, s'exécute et se gère sans
intervention humaine. Donc déclenchement
automatique. Donc un événement suffit.
Entrer d'un nouveau contact, une réponse
reçue, délis atteint. Donc il y en a qui
vont utiliser du NN pour faire ça.
Claude COD aussi est rendu capable de
faire ça avec le slash loop qui qui est
un skill qui va peut-être s'actionner à
chaque
matin à 9h du matin. Tu vas avoir une
loop qui va starter
même ou sinon
donc ouais c'est ça. Donc ça ça se
déclenche automatiquement. Pipeline sans
friction donc l'agent il tri classe
envoie relance mais à jour le CRM zéro
intervention annuelle.
Résultat, c'est du levier réel parce que
pendant que tu prends un appel peut-être
avec un client, le système contacte 300
prospect en parallèle. Donc il vont
faire des tches pendant que toi tu
travailles.
Puis le fil levier c'est que chaque
niveau multiplie.
Ce n'est pas qu'une différence de degré,
c'est une différence de mature de
nature. Excusez-moi.
Donc niveau 1 2, tu du fo 1. Niveau 3 5
tu à du x 5. Puis quand tu vas arriver
du niveau 6 et plus ton skill de faire
une tâche va voir va pouvoir
faire 30 fois le résultat que tu aurais
en temps normal parce que l' va
continuer à travailler. Ça on dit 30
fois mais au final ça peut être vraiment
plus ça peut être pendant un an de temps
les va travailler parce que tu as bien
fait tes fich process les va pouvoir
travailler de manière autonome et
efficace pendant un an de temps même
plus que ça tu comprends donc l'effet de
levier il se multiplie
euh donc ici la zone entrepreneure
c'est 6 à 10 donc 6 tu as des agents qui
sont délégués un agent un flux 7
multiaagent tu as plusieurs équipes
autonomes qui vont travailler 8 une une
orchestration des problèmes qui sont
croisés qui vont se travailler pour avir
une orchestration des différents fich
process euh par la suite neuf il va
avoir une organisation qui va être
augmentée va être dans la culture elle
va comprendre vers où on s'en va et va
pouvoir prendre des décisions en
fonction de la culture d'entre
entreprise du projet de ta vision va
savoir comment tu réfléchis pour pouvoir
orchestrer davantage et prendre des
autonomies puis il y a partenaire donc
il v une stratégie qui va être pilotée
donc ça qu'on va voir juste ici niveau 7
système multiagent donc des agents
spécialisés qui se passent qui se qui se
passent des tâches entre eux sans que tu
sois au milieu. Donc on voir un réseau
d'agent, peut-être un agent de
recherche, un rédacteur, un correcteur,
il se relie automatiquement. Donc il va
terminer une fiche process avec
peut-être justement un agent de
recherche, il va faire des recherches
selon une fiche process qui va être
hyper détaillé.
Puis peut-être que quand la la la
l'agent de recherche va terminer sa
recherche, ben elle va le chiper à un
rédacteur. Peut-être que lui à partir
des recherches qui a été fait va rédiger
un texte selon encore une fois une fiche
process qui est bien détaillée. Il aura
un correcteur par la suite pour aller
vérifier un double feedback pour si on a
bien respecté toutes les normes.
Peut-être que tu as un style
d'entreprise, peut-être que tu es tuas
une manière de rédiger qui est propre à
toi. Donc vraiment avoir des agents qui
vont se suivre.
Endoff intelligent. Donc le résultat
d'un agent déclenche le suivant. La
logique est dans le système, pas dans la
tête. Dans ta tête. Donc comme je
disais, ça va suivre de manière
automatique. Euh ce qui sembauche, donc
ajouter un agent, ça donne ajouter de la
capacité, pas un employé, pas une
formation. Donc, tu peux ajouter des
fiches de processus pour aiguiser le
résultat qui est attendu
sans nécessairement devoir engager
davantage.
La transformation de la tâche à
l'empire,
c'est pas l'outil qui change, c'est
l'architecture de comment tu travailles.
Donc avant c'était vraiment tu les tches
isolé ici c'est assistant connecté agent
autonome multiagent puis organisation
augmenté
donc
par la suite 8 10 l'orchestration
maintenant des papel I qui se croisent
se coordonnent se corrigent mutuellement
donc
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'il va avoir la différence entre lui
qui va tout se passer de étape de
recherche, rédaction, correction, ben ça
va être que tu vas avoir peut-être un
agent, ben un regroupement d'agents qui
va être au niveau des publications
LinkedIn. Fait que là, eux, ils vont
tout faire la partie rédaction,
correction, les recherches et cetera. il
va avoir en parallèle de ça peut-être un
agent qui va faire plus au niveau des
sales fait que là qui va contacter qui
va être un growth operator fait va
calculer puis qui va voir justement les
KPI puis qui va peut-être pouvoir même
réitérer justement pour optimiser les
processus de développement des affaires.
Puis en parallèle, tu peux en avoir un
autre qui est plus au marketing, un qui
est plus au soutien technique, un qui
est fait vraiment avoir différents
agents mais différents euh groupe
d'agents qui travaillent en parallèle
puis avoir une orchestration qui est
plus euh supérieure au-dessus de tout ça
qui va orchestrer euh tous les agents
pour que tout fonctionne bien. Niveau 9,
organisation augmentée. Donc dans la
culture de l'entreprise, chaque équipe a
ses agents. savoir si on allait.
OK, c'est ça. Donc euh ces ces agents
donc il va avoir des
l'équipe de ton entreprise va gérer des
différents groupes et va travailler
avec.
Puis L comme partenaire stratégique donc
L ne fait pas ne fait pas ne fait plus
les que les tâches. Elle participe aux
décisions. Donc là quand L est rendu
qu'elle possède un cerveau d'entreprise
qui est connecté partout à suit toutes
les KPI devient une sorte de référence
un second cerveau d'entreprise et on
peut
la elle va prendre elle peut
potentiellement prendre des décisions
pour l'entreprise et être vraiment euh
une duplication de les cerveaux des euh
des dirigeants du board fait que l' peut
faire partie du board.
Niveau 11, tu n'utilises plus l' te
représente. Donc
Lia va tellement connaître ton
entreprise, ça va tellement être plogé
partout qu'elle va être mieux que
n'importe qui pour prendre des décisions
pour l'entreprise. Après ça, ça va être
la touche humaine, ça va être le
jugement critique qui va euh dire les go
pour vraiment bien déterminer mais l'
pourrait bien représenter l'entreprise.
Pour la plupart des utilisateurs I, le
temps entre le niveau 5 et le 6, c'est
infini. Il n'y arrive jamais. Pas par
manque de talent, par manque de cadre
pour penser le passage.
Donc qui pense même pas que le passage
est possible.
Le vrai choix, soit tu restes dans ta
zone, donc confort routin vitesse, euh
tu utilises des outils plus vite, tu
gagnes quelques heures par semaine, tu
dépends encore de ta présence. L arrête
quand tu t'arrêtes. Donc tout là, tu vas
tout le temps être en mode il pas il
manque de quoi mais dans le sens que il
va avoir toujours un modèle qui va être
plus efficace. Il va tout le temps avoir
une IA plus à la mode puis tu vas tout
le temps passer euh pour aller vers tu
vas être attiré vers la robe rouge un
peu pour justement optimiser le fait que
tu es plus rapide. Là, tu vas te tu vas
passer ton temps justement à continuer à
faire du copiercollé mais peut-être
faire du meilleur prompting. Mais au
final, on s'en compte que c'est pas tes
promes qui sont nécessaires pour être
plus efficace.
C'est l'architecture que tu vas faire,
les fiches de processus que tu vas y
donner. Puis franchir la ligne, c'est là
que tu vas avoir des leviers du des
systèmes, la liberté. Donc, tu consèmes
qui travaillent pour toi. Chaque
investi, c'est un levier qui est
permanent. Donc tes fiches de processus,
quand tu vas la faire une fois, ben tu
vas la dupliquer pour toujours. Elle va
toujours pouvoir se faire et elle va
toujours être cohérente avec ce que tu
fais en temps normal. Mais il faut que
tu as des belles et des bonnes et euh
des bonnes fiches process. Tes résultats
ne dépendent plus de ta présence. Le
système continue sans toi.
Euh avant de fermer cette vidéo, trois
questions honnêtes. À quel niveau tu es
vraiment ?
Qu'est-ce qui t'empêche de passer au
niveau suivant sur ton temps, des
compétences, clarté sur comment faire
puis qu'est-ce que tu à chaque jour en
restant là à ce niveau-là ? Si des
heures, si ton énergie, les
opportunités, mets un chiffre là-dessus.
C'est quoi combien tu perds en temps, en
argent ? C'est comment tu perds ?
Donc la question c'est pas est-ce que tu
utilises l'IA ? C'est à quel niveau tu
veux t'arrêter.
Donc
c'est ça à quel niveau tu veux t'arrêter
? C'est sûr qu'il y a pas tout le monde
qui ont besoin de se rendre niveau 11,
tu sais.
C'est vraiment si tu as des projets, tu
as de l'ambition, tu veux optimiser ton
temps, ton énergie, tes investissements
pour tes projets.
Donc dans ce cas, l' est un excellent
outil.
Mais si tu es un salarié
ou peu importe, ben c'est sûr que tu as
des outils qui peuvent t'aider aussi
pour avoir des des agents qui
travaillent pour toi. Mais c'est sûr que
ça ça s'adresse pas à tout le monde une
vidéo comme ça des niveaux euh les
différents niveaux. Mais c'est
entrepreneur,
au moins tu tu as un besoin de
comprendre ça pour l'appliquer à tes
business potentiellement pour former tes
ton staff sur ces différents niveaux là.
Donc sur ce,
si cette vidéo te fait réfléchir,
abonne-toi à cette vidéo puis à cette à
ce compte puis en salut Bien.